you know mike i want to apologize for
the first hour we talked about how
late night tv was dead and they're not
doing any good skits
oh no and i think this is a really good
one you're gonna love it
okay honestly can we talk about
instagram for a second because this new
algorithm change i cannot like have
y'all seen this new update
what's happening and now a message from
the vice president-elect of the united
states
good evening this is your vice
president-elect gamala harris
next week the entire world will watch
the inauguration hey mike
that's not kamala harris that's lily
singh pretending to be kamal harris
that is can i just point out that is
like a
four dollar wig it's yeah it's a cheap
that's not even like you know at least
give snl credit
at least when snl whoever their makeup
and hair people are at least they really
get you to look like the person
that's a [ __ ] that's a wig from party
city
of president-elect joe biden and myself
she already had the clothes so before
the big day
i wanted to practice addressing plenty
of pants
oh yeah all right yeah she was with
listen trust me
lily sings been waiting for this moment
her whole life a half indian female pres
she's like oh my god i already have all
of the pants ready to go
yeah she shops at the paula poundstone
collection she's been waiting her whole
life for this moment
without anyone watching naturally this
time slot seemed like the perfect place
america we still don't know each other
that well
so let me take this time to reintroduce
myself
i'm kamela harris your vp your k-cup
your top cop you're a comma from a
different mama you're prosecuting you're
kamala sutra i have a lot
see what she's doing is she's taking
like all the memes all the funny little
memes that people said about her they're
not funny
and she's not hilarious and um she's
repeating them
and by the way everybody keeps pointing
out that lily sings attractive
she's attractive but trust me
i guarantee you she's one of those
tricks that probably tries to be funny
in bed you know what i mean she probably
talks a lot
trust me i i doubt i doubt at night with
lily sing would be
fun a lot of nicknames
but if you call me camela you can show
yourself out your girl didn't become the
first female
first black first indian vice president
by getting out hustle no
no she did it by sucking in a lot of
[ __ ]
by putting a lot of penises in her mouth
to the point that she got tired and then
at 50 decided to get married
i want to give a quick shout out
absolutely by the way yeah absolute god
well you notice all these like female
power brokers and politics
their husbands are all the same type of
guy
mother for teaching me to be such a
go-getter her hoo-ha was the first
barrier i broke through
and i'm not done breaking barriers some
people think
i'm just here trying to make myself look
cool to voters
no no lily that's what we think of you
and your show you're trying to make
yourself look cool to people
and you're not cool lily that's not true
just like you i grew up listening to
drake i don't
dubstep i take the first step
what by the way any any person with half
a brain would would point out that
she was made fun of for pretending to
listen to rap
i don't know why you'd bring that up
because it's not a thing i don't think
it's
something you want to highlight right
yeah
kamala harris didn't grow up listening
to drake okay
what a [ __ ] just what a
dumb thing to say so
gumtown has a funny bit now anytime they
talk about kamala
nick mullen just goes tupac
i just go hey uh kamala did you ever
watch the show friends who's your
favorite person on the show friends
tupac this is every answer is too
[ __ ] i have big plans here's my to-do
list for today
and it's just a list of politicians
but kamala that's all of congress it
says willie brown and it's crossed out
what does that mean
what does that mean and also tulsi
gabbard which is odd which is
you know i'd watch it i would i'd watch
it yeah
it's like one of those things it's one
of those like things when you're in your
20s and you can pull a threesome but one
of the girls is
like yeah what did you do i've done a
few of those in my 20s where you could
pull a threesome
and one you're like damn yeah the other
one you're like
she's freezing this is everything i've
already done today
and yes by today i mean since midnight
you could fill a book with the things
i've done that's just a list of all the
black men she's put in prison for life
that's page one three strikes what do
you want from me
midnight you could fill a book with the
things i've done
by things you mean people yeah and by
book you mean condom
[Laughter]
use condom paris
or a prison you cross me i cross-examine
you
wait did she actually just say fill a
prison yeah i think she did
she was it that's let me know that again
you could fill a book with the things
i've done or a prison
you cross me i cross-examine you
but that's but but according to you
that's a bad thing right
isn't that a bad thing supposed to be a
bad thing
yeah god man they have no consistency
they just don't
just ask brett kavanaugh he doesn't wear
robes because he's a justice no
he wears them to cover the bite marks i
took out of his ass
but he's but he's a supreme court
justice he didn't do anything
you didn't stop him he did fair you
didn't stop him
that would be a that would be a failure
on your part
so america we're gonna do big things
together over the next four years
and if you're afraid don't be because
there's a good chance i've already done
whatever you're scared to do
when they get when we well i mean i'm
scared to put black you know young black
men in jail for low-level drug crimes so
maybe she probably
i'm not put them on jail but
it's the only cool thing about kamala
harris but like
what's the end game like all right first
indian first woman black
whatever but like beyond that like
what's
what what are you what are these people
going to do when it dawns on them that
these people are not going to save them
or make their lives better
they'll turn they're going to turn on
these people too i mean that's it's
inevitable right
it's they're going to turn on them as
well they're going to call them
colonizers and turn
because you've weaponized all of these
people and you could say you could say
that it's a bunch of domestic white
but it's not they're going to turn on
you when you when you start not getting
your two thousand dollar checks
and when you start still being
unemployed and you know what i can't
wait for the thing that i'm
that i just can't wait to see not
personally it's gonna suck forever for
everybody but
when gas hits like five dollars a gallon
you could
donate that isn't a [ __ ] good luck
turning the people that hate five
dollars a gallon until
all those people that hate that it's a
white because it's gonna happen
and when it happens when gas gets
[ __ ] up there when the rest of the
country's paying california gas prices
people are gonna go i need to drive to
[ __ ] work what are you gonna tell
them take a bus
right has a new dog whistle and it's
complaining about gas prices
wait somebody time stamp this because i
know mike is joking
but how many times has this happened is
gonna be pictures and they're gonna use
footage of like truckers being
interviewed outside of love's
yeah i just think the prices are too
dang i look at that white
look at that neon i bet he hates black
people
you know well he he might because he's a
truck driver but that's not the reason
he's mad
i mean yeah i hate black people but i
hate high gas prices more
if that makes me a racist then i know
you're joking but you know that's going
to be the title of a huffpo article
in a flyblazer anyway i've got a run
i've got a 2 a.m zumba session do you
bet i'm cheating
i'm telling you man she's she's
i don't know how anybody could like
like date lily sing i just wouldn't
like you you ever like you dated a girl
you were hanging out around a girl
[ __ ] a girl that like
was physically attractive right but they
just kept doing or saying [ __ ] that over
time just
contributed to their overall score and
then eventually it's like i can't even
get hard for you at this point
like you've said said so many dumb ass
things
and you've you've just had so many
moments that are embarrassing that
i can't even get it hard for you anymore
i don't know how she keeps boyfriends i
just don't
teaching but don't worry i will be back
because
lily singh might be the first indian
woman to host a network
late night show but now i'm the first
vice president to take one over
i rest my case she and i also take one
in the [ __ ] mouth
um you noticed that she had to change it
to first indian woman because
not first woman anymore because yeah or
woman of color yeah
late night show but now i'm the first
vice president to take one over
i rest my case because she's a
prosecutor
and prosecutors normally rest her case
yeah cause we like prosecutors now
apparently yeah you don't i thought that
all ever the bastards are all bastards
all cops are bad yeah and then you know
who do they work with
good evening thank you
are you done are we what just happened
bro [ __ ] day hacked her show in real
time
i hate her i know i know it's like not
even it's not even heading to the
conversation i just hate her
i hate her that way i hate her
okay you know excuse me hi madam vice
president-elect kamala harris
i get you might be the second most
powerful person in the world but i need
to make it clear
she's not going to see this like
everyone else in america
yeah no she's gonna go uh yeah
can i get that uh on that jimmy kimmel
i'm gonna go do stephen colbert i am the
most powerful person
except for like maybe my show runner
maybe even the covet compliance officer
maybe even my editor they have a coveted
compliance officer
probably imagine living in that world
we do we live in this no no no i get it
but imagine imagine imagine having a job
where you have to
have a coveted compliance officer
and it's actually just tom cruise
yelling at everybody
[Laughter]
screaming at the top of his lungs we are
giving jobs to people
all right dude jesus tom relax we are
personally saving the world
i mean we're just making a movie it's
it's we're making mission impossible 17.
uh you know why i'm happy
because they didn't have enough they
didn't have enough other ones to really
tell the story of mission impossible but
now i really think they're going to wrap
it up nicely
i mean you guys already killed philip
seymour hoffman you know you should just
end it by now
maybe even my editor because they could
cut me off at any time
her editor got her off by the way i
don't see how that's any different from
your regular editing
like your regular editors have done
terrible jobs
all right so she's great she's she's
just she's fantastic i i love it
i i don't think she gets enough credit
for being awesome i don't know indian i
guess